Good evening to all,
Sir.
All good evening,
uh, sun, is it getting reflected in the Dr. Sun?
Uh, sir, that I think you have made changes in some other
File. Let me
look into it.
Check in. No network introduction only.
I have done it before starting the propagation.
Ah, yes, sir. The, just
after that, uh, title page of web application. I'm
Okay. Okay.
Okay. So yes, we are in the same file.
I can see you.
Yes, sir.
I think, uh, which slide number it is, sir?
Let me check. 8 59.
Um, this is, let me see. Uh,
Yeah, slide number 50.
Okay. 50. Yes. Yes.
52. Uh, 57.
Yes, sir. Yes. Those things.
Yes, it's fine, sir.
Yeah, you can share the screen.
Okay. I, I'll share, sir. It's,
yes, sir.
Yeah, just go to the previous slide. Okay. Okay.
Okay, tk, uh, shall we start?
Yes, sir. We can start. I guess.
So, uh, good evening all.
Um, um, a quick recap.
Uh, I think we discussed about, uh, we started
with, uh, the basic computing element, perceptron,
where the step function
or hard limiting function is the output function.
A single layer of perceptron can deal
with linearly separable classes.
If the classes are not linearly separable, then we need
to add more layers of perception.
Uh, and again, the, the, the class
of problems which are not linearly, sufferable are again,
divided into two broad categories, which are, um,
convex in nature and which are non convex in nature,
which are convex in nature.
Then I can have one more layer of perception, two layers
of perception, one input layer, um, that will help us
to deal with the machine learning tasks,
which are not linearly separable,
but the hyper surfaces can form convex surfaces.
The non convex part, we have to add one more, um,
layer of perception.
And with that three layers of perception, one input layer,
that is called as a multi-layer perception.
With that, we are able to overcome the challenges of
what are called the representation problems,
how the problems we used to see we are, we are able
to represent that, uh, that we say we will be able to
construct the hyper surface, non-line hyper surface,
which can separate the data points of,
uh, different classes.
And so this resulted in,
uh, now coming up
with a new multi-layer feed forward neural network
architecture, where framework wise, it showed that
it is indeed possible to, um,
um, come up with a neural network model, uh,
which can deal with problems of different complexity,
linearly supportable, not linear supportable,
but con in nature.
Next one is not linear is non convex also.
So all that degree of con complexities we can deal
by taking multi-layer percept.
Now the issue is, uh, that the, that resulted in solving,
getting some high hypothesis solution for, uh,
the hard problems.
Okay. And so
with that, people are able to say, yes,
now we can deal with such problems.
But it in turn resulted in a very important
big bottleneck in the neural network theory.
Uh, and that is what, uh, resulted in the
development of a new algorithm
for training such a multi-layer perceptron called
as bap propagation.
The genesis behind
that I will explain then Tar Sunil will take
over the rest of the part.
Next slide. Sunil here
for no, uh, just for, um, a simplicity sake,
I have taken from this book, uh, a three layer network where
there is one input layer, which is all the
neurons are linear in nature, output functions are linear,
whereas there are two perceptron layers output layer,
and the in between one layer is there,
which is cause the hidden layer,
the nomenclature given is hidden layer.
And with that, uh, so suppose you just take a three layer
feed form network will linearly inseparable problems,
but, uh, which where the hyper we can form convex surfaces
with the, at the hyper surfaces at the output
of the, they can be dead.
But the very important, uh, thing, uh, they found out was
after proposing this framework,
see when machine learning tasks are
given, since input outputs are given for training network,
that is a supervised learning task.
Now, when machine learning tasks are given, they,
you are given input data points
and the corresponding output data points.
If you recall perception learning law,
if you know the target output
and the actual output coming out of this neuron,
you can find the error.
If you know the error, you can adjust the weights
for the links leading to that particular output neuron.
But the challenge is, if I go to the hidden layer,
I don't know what should be the output of this.
This is a very, very important point to appreciate.
The rest of the explanation that we do what is given
to us in a given machine learning task is only the input
to the input layer and the output to the output layer.
So once I have the target output for the output layer
and apply the input data, it flows from left to right.
That's why it's called feet far.
And at the output of each
of the neurons in the output layer,
you get the actual output.
Yes. Then once I have target output B
and the actual output test B minus S delta error, I get,
I can adjust the weights of the links leading
to the neurons in the output layer.
But if I go to the hidden layer, I don't know
what is the target output there
because it is not available to us.
This is a very important point.
At the hidden layer, we don't know the target output
if I don't know the target output.
Uh, uh, because even though structurally we show
these output nodes are not directly available
for external tapping, what we have is only the input nodes
for the input layer and the outputs
of the output layer are only visible to the external wire.
The hidden layer is hidden.
That's why the name hidden has come.
You don't have access to the outputs of those
neurons in the hidden layer.
And since I don't know the target output
of the hidden layer neurons, so
accordingly, I cannot compute the, the, uh, error
between the target output
and the actual, if I don't know, know the error.
I cannot apply perceptron learning
to the hidden layer neurons.
So accordingly, I will not be able to adjust weights for the
links leading to the neurons hidden layer.
This is a very, very, very important statement.
And the same thing, suppose you pictorially,
you can visualize, I will put one more hidden layer here,
hidden layer one, layer two,
But, but for both the hidden layers,
I don't have the target output.
So accordingly, I will not be able to adjust weight
for both the hidden layer, one, hidden layer, uh, two, uh,
links leading, leading links leading to those hidden layers.
Okay, so, uh, so,
and even though framework wise they told no,
you take three layer, I can do convex problems
and I take four layer.
I can do non convex problems also,
but the, we ended up, we are able to give some solution,
hypothetical solution for
hard problems.
Whereas it, this resulted in another problem,
what is called, uh, unable to adjust the weights of
links leading to a done layer one
and two, uh, in the case of four layer network,
hidden layer one, one layer in case of three layer network.
'cause I don't know the target. Okay?
So as a result of that, I'm not able to learn the weights
of the links leading to the, uh, links of the done layer.
And this problem is called as hard learning problem.
This problem is called as a hard learning problem. Okay?
And so as a result of that,
the whole neural network field know, uh,
took a backseat for nearly a decade or so.
People don't know how to train such a network, just like,
uh, deep learning networks, frameworks or propose,
but people don't know to train the deep neural network
models in the same way.
These feedforward networks, even though architectures
or proposals, There is no way they can
demonstrate how to train such network.
And this problem
therefore propose it as
what is called a hard learning problem.
Hard problem means a representation problem,
hard learning problem is learning.
Difficulty in learning are training the feedforward neural
network, and that's where know,
nearly one decade people try different algorithm.
Nobody is able to do.
That's why the whole neural network field was stands still.
Finally, after a decade of, uh, silence,
the bap propagation learning was learning algorithm was
proposed, and,
and that is how again, it gave a rebirth
to the neural network field.
And according, you know, feed forward network,
the work car algorithm for training, the feed
for network is the B application learning algorithm.
And they overcame, they came up with a method for
overcoming the hard learning problem in the case of feed
for neural network that we'll see.
Next slide. Uh, sweet.
What they did was,
see the hard limiting function was there in the,
uh, perceptron.
If I have an hard limiting function step function
from your high school, uh, differential, uh,
high school calculus, if you see,
if I have a discontinuous function, like a step function,
I do not know the derivative at the discontinuous place
and at all other points, no.
Suppose if you remember a step function, which is say zero
and one or minus one
and one, there is an horizontal line at zero and one,
and there is a transition happening at the origin.
Every wave, the slope is zero, except
that the discontinuous point
you consider this itself a step function will be like this,
the zero line and the vertical line,
and there is an horizontal line coming there.
When, when the, the constant value,
the differential is zero, they will take a line at
that point as a discontinuity.
Okay? So, so as a result of that, uh,
we, uh, the, um,
Of course just for a target output only
for the output layer is okay,
but in spite of, in, in, in, in lie of that step function,
I need a non-linear function as the output function.
So they propose what are called sigal
functions as the output function.
These are also non-linear sigal function,
but they're differential non-zero differences there.
For example, if I take a logistic function,
it varies from zero to one.
This is the logistic function definition.
F of X is zero to one, one
by one plus exponential minus two BIX, where BIX
as a function of x, this varies from zero to one.
You substitute beta equal to zero,
then I will have one by one.
So, so one plus this exponential
of my two beta, that will be two.
This is one, one plus one by two.
At that point, it is 0.5 and beta X.
Uh, for example, X is zero, 80 point
or minus zero is one, one plus one is two.
One by two is 0.5. RT X equal to zero.
Beta X will be this eight.
Exponential of minus two beta X will be
one, one plus one is two.
That's how one by two will be 0.5.
And as you go on, increase the X value, it rises quickly
and saturates to one.
Similarly, X goes in the negative direction,
quickly goes down.
And, but what is important is, see if I take the
differential of this F dash x, this is f dash x second
function, you take, no,
there is a non-zero differential available here,
non-zero differential available here.
So in this region, it is possible to differentiate.
If it is possible to differentiate then the error
that is computed at the output layer with the help
of this differentiable output function.
I can pass on that, uh, error
to the previous layer, previously done layer.
Okay? And mathematically they showed that the,
can you go back to the previous, uh, slide, uh, Sunni
previous, uh, uh, this slide.
See now in the output layer, I make, uh, um,
a nonlinear output sigmoidal function.
Then this becomes differential.
Then I can express the error.
At this point, the done layer output as the,
in terms of the difference of the, the error here will be
expressed in terms of the errors
or the output of each of the neurons.
But in the differential form, I take the differential form
and submit the mathematically they have shown.
So even though I don't know the target output
of the done layer, I can bap propagate the error
from the output layer.
Okay? That is why the name called BAP propagation learning
algorithm came into picture.
Okay, next slide. Uh,
either you can see both are sigal function.
Either you can use this logistic function
or the T hyperbolic function.
If I go over tana hyperbolic function,
it varies from minus one to plus one
because this is the equation tan,
then it's differential is the F dash
effects will be like this.
What do you see that now for a small region
around origin X equal to zero, there is a non-zero, uh,
differential function with the help of that.
By operating the, uh, output values in that range,
I can back propagate the error
of the output layer to the previous layer.
Same way you can continue further previous layers also.
Okay, next slide.
And these points, I told this hard learning problem.
So pattern mapping involves finding weight.
Given a set of involve, it should be known
that no, the desired output for in the hidden
and the output layers it necessary to know.
But once the desired output is known, error
for each unit may be used to guide the output rates leading
to this desired output on available only
for the output units in the,
for the units in the output layer, not
for the units In the A layer, this statement is important.
Desired output is known only
for the units in the output layer,
but not the units in the A layer.
Okay, so a
accordingly no, a learning rule
that depends on the difference between the desired open,
the actual output is not feasible in this case.
So accordingly, no, the problem of updating weights
in the done layer became impossible.
And hence it is supposed as a hard learning problem.
Hard problem is different compared to hard learning problem.
If you're not able to represent in the architecture,
they're called as the hard problems.
But if you're not able to adjust the weights of some
of the hidden layers, then it
becomes a hard learning problem.
Okay, next slide.
So for that purpose, as I explained there, instead
of using a step function, they came up
with a differential output function.
So this hard learning problem can be solved using a
differential nonlinear output function for each
of the unit in the hidden layer and output layers.
So the corresponding learning law is based
around propagating the error from the output layer
to the hidden layers for updating the weights.
So this is an error correcting law also collect
generalized delta rule.
Generalized delta rule means, uh, the uh, uh,
delta rule is nothing about percept and discreet percept
and learning law we have, but the discrete ness of percept
and learning law is applicable only to the output layer.
But I can, by converting the hard limiting
output functionality, differential output function, I can
extend that delta learning law, um, um,
into the previous layers also.
And that's why it's called a generalized delta learning law.
Okay? Means I can pass on that delta learning law too.
Uh, generalize it to the hidden layers,
also ends the name generalize delta.
Okay, next slide. So
what is the BAP application learning algorithm framework?
It is the learning algorithm.
The propose is for the multi-layer feed for network.
It is also termed as generalize delta rule.
Um, a gradient descent along the error surface arrive to a,
that is okay, that is a different thing.
Error. We know spare difference
between the output and the actual output.
Obtain the output layer of the network.
Then you estimate the gradient descend along the error
surface to increment weight connecting the unit.
And so what we do is,
for example, the change in the weight
is proportional too.
The partial derivative with reference
to the ER partial derivative with reference to the error
and that use it as a change in the rate.
This delta earlier, it used to be the discrete delta,
no target output minus this one.
That ER is there directly proportional the data.
Now it is made as a derivative proportional
to the derivative of the TR.
That is, this is the change they made
when they came up with this propagation.
We'll go to the next slide.
Um, so deriving the expressions
for this delta WAJ for different layers.
Suppose if you consider a multi-layer perception
with three layers output, one hidden three layers,
input one hidden and output, that is what has shown
that figure, that three layer network has shown.
The first layer will go back to that slider.
Um, Sunil, Ah,
the first layer is represented 1, 2, 3, et cetera.
Small I and capital I.
Capital i number of neurons in the input layer,
the hidden layer, the neurons are represented
by J small J one, two, et cetera.
Capital J, small J is the index similar,
the neurons in output layer as one, two,
small K, et cetera, capital.
Okay, that is how the notation, we'll go back to
that go forward next.
Ah, c, the first layer as capital I,
linear input units indexed by small I second layer
as capital J.
Linear nonlinear units indexed by J
and the third layer as capital K,
nonlinear units indexed by small
KEFM
Is the given is given at the input layer.
And the desired output is BFM is available
only at the output layer.
So error between the desired output, BFM
and the actual output.
B dash M is available only at the output layer.
So use this error to adjust the weights from the input units
to input hidden units.
That's why now there are weights in the two layers.
One, the weights leading from the output
of the ED layer to the output layer.
They're called WKJ
because you see now J is the ED layer, neuron
K is the output layer neuron.
Similarly, the the neuro weights from input layer I to
ed layer J is WHJJ super split is given just
to differentiate between, uh, the two set of weights.
Okay, next slide.
So now we'll see I'm quickly recalling the
discrete percept on learning law that we discussed earlier,
uh, because we are using a step function there.
That's why it's called discrete percept learning, blah,
delta WL is nothing
but e equal to ETA delta
A delta is bi minus signal of W transpo.
This we discussed earlier.
Then, uh, for this is for the particular neuron,
and the J link in the neuron is given WIJ.
And this is what, uh, every neuron link.
This is the weight application parameter.
This is, this is just, I'm recalling
that what we discussed today.
Please remember this equation here.
Uh, the weight application equation is given
by target output minus the actual output
where actual output output function is a step function,
signum function multiplied
by the input A go to the next slide.
In the continuous perception law, our delta learning law,
please make a note of this.
Instead of signum function, I'm using ef,
where f can be any non differentiable output function.
Sig modal is a differential output function.
Now, the change in the error is made proportional to
the error, uh, multiplied by
the differential of the actual output.
Uh, this is differential differential with reference to
that particular weight do by do w with reference
to the w transpo.
This term is extra. F dash term is extra.
This is not there in the discreet learning law.
Now, what we are doing is we are making the change in the
weight also proportional to the, uh, partial
derivative of the error, um,
at the output layer.
But that at any point of time, I can express
that error in terms of the output layer.
So that is how the whole derivation is there.
Maybe that is beyond the scope of your course.
If somebody's interested, can watch some videos.
They're explaining no, a three layer network, they take
and show it, but F dash exceed
derivative with reference to X.
Okay? I think derivative with reference to j uh,
if you take a dash X, but
otherwise, so you where
si is the actual output at the iTune.
So now what we are trying to do here is
we convert a discreet perception learning law into a
continuous perception learning law
or delta learning law, where
the change in the way it is proportional to earlier,
like that they are put in the target
and this one multiplied by
the differential of the, uh, output,
differential of the output.
That is what, uh, uh, we are going to do.
So with the help of that, uh, you can pass on.
For example, uh, just to summarize,
I compute the error only at the output layer.
I, I express that error pass back, propagate that error
into the output of the hidden layer one.
Then once I have the back propagated error at the hidden
layer one, I can adjust the weight for the, uh,
le links leading to the hidden layer one.
Then I can back propagate the error from
the hidden layer one to the output of the hidden layer two.
Using that, I can adjust the weights for the one.
And you, you, you can see, I can express the weights
that any of the done layer in terms of the error,
the output layer, that is what, uh, is, uh, the
uh, um, basic breaking idea
of the ba propagation learning block.
What is that? The two for, for, for one decade,
except this F dash w transpose ea,
everything else was there.
They were not knowing what to do.
Once they brought this differential output function,
suddenly they were able
to train the network in the this one.
Next slide is, uh, I think
before this you go back.
Just to summarize, um,
In a multi-layer feedforward neural network,
we can b propagate the errors from the output layer
to hidden layer outputs.
Once IB propagate
and I have the error now presented the hidden layer using
them, you can adjust the weights at the hidden layer.
But I was telling no B propagate the error.
B propagate the error, but I'm telling it is a
feed forward neural network.
There is no way a signal flow will happen always in the
feed forward network.
The signal flow happens from the input to the output layer.
Now, I said many times that propagation of error,
which which gives in the mind that no,
there is a connection going back from the output layer
to the input layer.
That is not happening mathematically.
We are expressing the, uh,
out error value at the output of the hidden layer in terms
of the error value at the output layer.
Similarly, the mathematically,
we are expressing the error at the output of the first
and second layer to be output of the,
there is a derivation there,
but it is beyond the scope of your, uh,
no course if somebody's interested can study it.
Okay? I think with this I'll stop maybe, uh, I request,
uh, Sunil to take over.
Uh, yes, thank you sir.
If anyone has any questions so far, you can Yeah,
Please let me know.
The f fs f least the sigma function only,
not only function if dash is its DER user
or it's a loss function.
If here
This output function to produce the neuron output,
there's an output function required.
Okay? In the traditional perception,
we were using only be that step function, okay? Okay.
At layer, huh? At the output layer, sir?
At the output layer, there is only,
but you can't now, uh, now that output layer also now needs
to be replaced with a non-linear output function.
Okay? Uh, of course you can keep, if you want still
for a classification task,
you can still keep it as a step function.
Yeah, because that weight adjustment I can do,
but the hidden layers, you have
to convert them into differential output,
differential output functions.
So the we see in the slide is only for output layers.
Otherwise, uh, the hidden layer will be having sigma
that, uh, this is for
Hidden layer we'll be having.
Ah, correct, correct, correct, correct, correct, correct.
No, these, these, these formulas are for the hidden layers.
Oh, okay. Okay.
'cause you can't differentiate, uh,
the output function if it is a step function, no.
Correct. Okay. Correct. This f dash will be zero.
Okay. Okay.
See, I already have the, uh, already I have the error
directly computed at the output layer,
Right?
And I want to express that in the form of
representative error at the output of within layer.
Okay? Uh,
that I can compute only when I have a
differential output function.
Okay? Okay. Yeah.
I just wanted to confirm how it's different from the
error function itself, right?
So the last function we have, right?
Uh, so is it, is it any related to
Which last function?
The error, right? The error basically is the
last function will have,
Ah, see the error, uh, see what we are talking is,
um, the cf r, nothing but the output function.
There is, in neuronal function,
there is an output function required,
Right? Okay. We are
Talking about this f represent the output
Function. Okay, sir? Yeah,
that's clear. Thanks. Um,
Of, we will see the, when, when, with example,
Sunil says we will see how it, uh, goes.
But there is a theory, but I don't want to, uh,
go detail with that.
Okay, sir. Thank you. Thank you.
Excuse me, sir. One more though.
Yes, Sir. Actually, this ash is partial
Derivative or, uh, Partial derivative.
Partial derivative, okay. Partial derivative location.
Okay, next slide.
Hmm, maybe Sunil, you may have
to clarify when in these examples, uh,
where do we can use step function?
Where do we use? Uh, yes sir. This one? Yeah.
Fine, sir. Thank you. Alright, so, uh,
I'll take you through one, one example with one data set
and scenario, and then with that I'll try to explain
how this back propagation works for one iteration.
And, uh, at the end, we will also see the,
uh, uh, demo in PyTorch that how to implement this, uh,
back propagation, right?
So this is the overall structure Whater has explained.
Just now that we have the feed forward neural networks here,
it is shown left to right, the input is here, X one, x,
x one, and X two is an input, and this is the input layer.
Then we have first hidden layer, which is shown here in
blue, and we have the second hidden layer shown in green,
and we have the output layer, which is in purple.
So that is how we have, uh, uh, you can, uh, treat it
as four layers, including the hidden layers.
Okay? So now ev in, at every layer, first of all,
what you have to understand that, uh, you,
you will have some number of neurons, as you can see here,
it is indicated as three neurons at first layer,
four neurons at second layer, one neuron at
final layer or output layer.
You can say that, okay?
And the way neuron works, it is same,
the working principle
of the neurons are not changing in the sense we calculate
the Z, which is nothing but the weighted sum, okay?
And in, uh, which, which also includes the bias
and that we follow, we pass it through the, um,
activation function F, right?
So if you can recall from the perceptron,
this f was always step function, right?
But that, that, that itself, sir, was, uh, explaining
that step function because you cannot
differentiate the step function.
So later on, we have kept all these functions.
What you see here in this layer, this layer at as well
as in the output layer, that all these stiff functions
are differentiable.
Uh, all these functions are differentiable, um, functions.
That is what we have kept, so that, uh, at the time
of the back propagation, it'll help us.
I'll explain that one. How, how does it work?
So what happened with the Feedforward network,
you get the prediction, right?
It's a network, it's a,
it's a machine learning model, neural network.
And hence it will give us a prediction.
Now, this prediction, we compare with our true value,
because that is what we do in, in, in case
of the supervisory learning, right?
So we have a prediction, we have a true value,
and we calculate the loss.
So suppose prediction is five,
and we have to calculate eight.
Then loss will be, absolute loss will be three. Okay?
Eight minutes, five is equal to three.
Say that now, once you get a loss here, okay?
Now think from the perspective that why this loss is why,
why this loss from where this loss has come,
because we have never fed the wrong input
and whatever output we are expecting, that is also with us.
So input output is already available with us in our data,
but then also we are getting a loss.
We are not able to predict what we want to predict.
That means that somewhere in this network,
something has gone wrong.
Right? Now, what, what, what,
what can go wrong in this particular network input output
anyway, it is fixed for a given data set, right?
So that we can't be changing, right?
So input output you will have fixed in your data set.
Then if you see in this particular network,
you have these connections, these weights in the form
of weights and biases between input
and hidden layer, first hidden layer, second hidden layer,
second hidden layer and output layer.
These are the weights, the way we have initialized them
that might have gone wrong, okay?
That might have gone wrong.
That is just, uh, uh, you can say that the, uh, uh,
uh, hypothesis what I have.
So then what we can do, the,
what we can do is we can adjust these weight
because I need to get the output Y by,
but I'm getting Y dash.
So, uh, we, we got to know
that these weights are responsible
because we have not initialized them in a way, uh, uh,
in a way, uh, so that it could have
converted the mapping right from X to Y.
So the only possibility is that we need
to change these weights.
We need to change these weight. That's itself is called
as the learning for this neural network, right?
So what we do, that's
where this back propagation
algorithm comes into the picture.
So what we start thinking that, okay, here we have a loss.
Now, this loss we are getting,
and who is responsible for it?
These weights are responsible for this particular loss.
So if I slightly change the weights, it may happen
that whatever output I'm, uh, I, I'm looking for
that I'll get in, in the form of prediction.
So what I'll start doing, I'll start
changing these parameters
or, uh, parameters like say weights or biases.
So I'll slightly change these parameters on of this layer,
this layer and this layer, okay?
And once suppose all these parameters are changed again,
we will feed, say that the same input, you can check
or you can feed the next input also in, in your dataset.
Okay? So you see
that there is a feed forward propagation, which always happens.
First, you get the loss,
and to reduce this loss,
then you start changing these weights.
You start changing these weights, obviously with, uh, uh,
for keeping, okay?
How much loss you have got.
That's why we take partial derivative of loss with respect
to these weights, because we have to see that, okay,
if I change loss a little bit, how much change, it'll,
sorry, if I change weight a little bit,
how much change it'll bring to the loss.
That itself is a partial derivative, right?
So that's why we slightly change these weights,
and we do the partial, and that's, that's
what it is shown here in the back propagation, layer
by layer, we try to update these weights,
and then again, we do the same process, feed forward again,
calculate the loss, and this process continues.
You can do it for some number of filtration,
and you'll see that, okay, loss is changing
or not reducing, or not, okay?
Accordingly, you can take the next curve.
So this is what happens in the case of training
of a neural network, okay?
Now, it can be any la any,
any layers which you can add in between.
It can be here we have the two layers,
which you have added in between,
but can go three layer, four layer, 10 layer,
a hundred layers, whatever it is, right?
In the large language models, you will see
that people have tried this one with 96 layers,
more than a hundred layers,
and this is fully connected layer.
There. We have used even more complicated kind
of architectures, but this is what happened
with the feed proper forward and backward preparation.
Now, what I will do is I will take one example, okay?
I will, and this example where we have two inputs, IQ
and C, GP of a student,
and we need to predict
what will be the package of a student.
And these are, say that four set of, uh, uh, of input
or per pair we have in our data set, okay?
And we are going to use this one,
although we are not going to show for every, uh, every row,
but I'll show you for the first row, okay?
So just, just for the demo purpose.
So, and what, what we'll do is we will try
to create a similar network, three inputs.
Three inputs. Why I am saying that X one,
X two will come in, will come from iq,
and C-G-P-A-X three will be my bias, which is going
to be fixed, okay?
So I will create this, this particular network first,
and there will be one hidden layer with the two neuron,
H one and H two, and there will be one output layer
where you will have single neuron, which is saying, which,
which will tell you, okay, how much LPA, uh, what,
what will be the LPA for a given input.
Okay? So this is the architecture which I'm going
to build fine.
Now, when it comes to the activation function,
I'll use a activation function in the head and layer, okay?
And I'll use linear activation function at the output layer.
Okay? So, uh, this is, this is, this is what is the plan,
and we are going to build a fully connected network.
So how it'll look like, it'll look something like this.
So I have two inputs, IQ and CGPA,
and obviously one more input in the form of bias,
which will be fixed as one.
So B one and B two and B three. All these B are biases.
We are going to fix H one, so to, to,
to a particular neuron.
So here there are three neurons.
In the hidden layer, you have two neurons, H one s two,
and in the output layer you have single neuron,
which is why, because you are going to,
it's a regression type of problem, isn't it?
So, uh, we are going to keep here a single neuron,
which will give us the output
and whatever output this neuron will give, we are going
to pass it to the linear, uh, uh, activation function.
So the output will be same, the, uh,
what we're getting, uh, from this neuron.
And in the hidden layer, we will have an, uh,
radio activation function, right?
Uh, that we are going to use it.
Now, we'll see that how the power propagation works,
and then how the backward propagation, uh, uh,
we will, we'll see that.
How does it work? So what will happen, uh, input X one,
X two i, Q, and C, GPA, and these are the weights.
So that W one one, W one, two, uh, are the weights,
which is coming from the first input that is called iq,
W one one, W one two.
And from cz PA, we have the weight W2 one, W 22 from B one,
B two, also, you have one, one weights,
which is coming similarly from H one S two also,
uh, our weights are coming.
So what I have done is I have given some
notation to these weights.
W one one, W one, two, going to H one, W2 one, W2 two, going
to H two V one, and V two going to Y.
So these are the weights.
What I have now, few more things in the forward PA pass.
What, what we'll do, what will happen to this H one,
H one will take the weighted sum, right?
That means that X one will get multiplied with W one,
one X two will get multiplied with W one two,
and B one will get multi B one, uh, will get multiplied
with, or B one, uh, with multiplied would say
that there is a weight called B one itself.
Okay? So I'm telling the B one is a weight, uh,
and one with the B one will be B one itself.
So hence you will get here W one one X one
W one one X one plus W one two X two plus B one H at H one.
Similarly, if HH two, you will get W2 one X one,
W2 two X two B two.
So it's a weight sum, right?
And then once you get that one, you pass it a function,
although it showed at a sigma,
but it's not sigmoid here, just a representation
of a function here, we are going to use a
activation function, as I have already
told in the previous slide.
So obviously then what we'll get,
we'll get some output from H one, H two, once we'll pass it
through this particular activation function.
Now, whatever output we'll pass, we'll get from H one S two,
we'll pass it as an input to the next layer.
So that output will get multiplied with V one.
So V one into H one, V two into H two plus V three.
Now this is going to be my what. Okay?
So what I've done is I have done the calculations for you,
you can see that later,
and do it by yourself also, just to understand, okay,
how exactly it happens, how, what is the flow and all,
because you can do it for the, uh, uh, very complex network.
But this is a very simple network,
and you should do the practice by on with your hands so
that those things, you will understand it better.
So X one is 80, and X two is eight.
In the first row of my dataset, if you can recall, 80
and eight and output is three.
That is what I'm going to use. B one, B two. B three is one.
And these are the weights values.
So what I have done is I have passed, uh, uh, this, this,
first of all, I've calculated W one one x one W one two,
X two B one, which has come, um, which has, which has come,
uh, so this one, 1.6 plus four plus one, which has come
to 6.6, which is a positive number.
So if you'll pass it through the relu, it'll take the output
as 6.6, right?
Because the activation function, as we have seen earlier,
it is max of zero comma,
whatever is this particular output is set.
So if that is positive, the output of the relu will be
that number, it's jet itself.
And if it is negative, obviously the zero is maximum.
So zero will be the output.
So here from H one, we are getting the output at 6.6.
After passing through the activation function,
and from S two, we are getting 1.8.
Now, what we'll do finally at the output layer,
we will solve this equation.
Now we have all the value H one S two,
we have, we wanna be two.
Anyway, we have, these are the weights,
and we get the output at 10.36.
So this is my prediction at the output layer right?
Now, once you get the prediction, the next thing is
to calculate the loss.
So once we have this prediction at why,
why hat we calculate the loss, say that I'm Cal
because it is a regression based problem,
so I'm using mean square loss, okay?
And, uh, how, what is the mean square loss?
So you y minus Y cap,
and you will say the square of that one,
which is coming y value, you have three y cap is coming
as 10.36.
So this value will come as 54.16.
Now here, I'm taking only square error, uh,
not the mean square error
because I just have one data point.
So all, although I'll take the mean, it'll be the same
because end value is one here.
In this case, if suppose you will pass, say
that in the batch three inputs together,
then this end value will come into the consideration
here, and it's one itself.
So this, this value will be, uh,
the mean square in this particular case.
Now, this error is so high.
So the best case
for the regression is when there is zero, right?
But then we are at 54, it's too high,
and then we have to reduce this error.
That's the whole intention.
So who is the responsible for this?
As I have talked, maybe, uh, these weights,
the way we have initialized, that's where we have,
we might have done some mistakes
and hence we'll make an effort
to change all these parameters.
Now, we don't know, okay, by changing V one
or V two, it may, it may happen
that it'll improve the error drastically,
that it'll reduce error, but that, that clue we don't have.
So what we'll do, we will change every parameter associated
with net associated with this network, okay?
And we will change every parameter up slightly just to see
that, okay, uh, what happens
in there error whether we increase or we decrease, okay?
That is how we slightly change.
So we use the partial derivative for that one. Okay?
So now it comes to the back propagation.
So far we have seen, okay, how the forward propagations are
being calculated.
So as I said, why do we get a loss
and why back replication is needed that I think
that motivation is clear, right?
So now, now here it comes the bap replication algorithm,
and just, just follow me, although the notations
and all will look a little, uh, complicated,
but then I will take you through the, uh, uh, take you
through the animation and with the pictures to show you
how exactly the error flows back
or back propagate in the network, okay?
With the, with the pictures. But then a little bit
of notation, that is what you have to follow, okay?
So say that the loss is being, uh, denoted
by this L.
So what we need to compute, if you see
that in this whole network, this is my network right now,
what is the parameters we have?
We have V one, V two, B three, okay?
And if I come to the previous layer, I have W one,
one W one two, W2, one W2 two and B one and B two.
Now these are the parameters. How many parameters?
We have three parameters in this layer,
and four plus two six parameters in this layer,
six plus three nine parameters.
That is what we need to update. Okay?
So when in order to update the parameter, first of all,
we need to see that, okay, how much, how much, uh, uh,
uh, what is the, uh, you can say that, uh, uh,
if I will change, support this B three a little bit, okay?
Uh, then what will be the change in L?
So what I want to calculate is I want
to calculate the error, partial derivative of the error
with respect to say B three,
because I told you right in the previous slide here,
why we are getting this error.
We are why we are getting the error here.
Maybe V one is responsible,
or V two is responsible for that, okay?
Or B three is responsible, okay? All error.
Maybe these are the weights with, uh,
the way we have initialized them, that's
where we must have gone wrong.
The right combination of these parameters we don't have,
and hence we are getting the error.
So we are, we start changing every parameter slightly.
So partial derivative of loss with respect to say B three.
So parcel derivative of loss with respect to B three.
What does it mean if I slightly change B three? Okay?
What will be the change in the law loss?
Okay, so you just assume that you have y uh, access
and xxi, okay?
Where we calculate the slope.
So if you change slightly x, what will be the change in Y?
Okay? That is what slope says. Slope always says.
So this partial derivative is nothing but a slope.
It's a gradient with nothing but a slope.
So what we calculate, if I slightly change B three,
what will be the change in the
what will the change in the loss similarly for B one,
similarly for B two and so on,
for all the parameter, and that's why this partial.
So what, so if you see this notation, this first one,
what we need to compute is partial derivative of loss
with respect to V one and then V two.
So VK K represents one and two, okay?
Similarly, if I talk about these weights,
so partial derivative of loss with respect to W one, one,
W one, two, W2, one, W2, two.
So it's represent, represented WIG. Okay?
1, 1, 1, 2, 2, 1, 2, 2.
And finally, this partial derivative of loss with respect
to B, bk, BK represents B one, B two, B three.
Okay? So that is how, uh, this, this key values are, uh,
going say that, okay?
And once suppose we have these values that, okay, how much,
uh, partial derivative, okay?
What will be that, uh, slope? Okay?
What will be that gradient?
So these are all called as gradient.
Then we can change these parameters with this update.
So VK will be VK minus, uh, we use the learning rate right
into this particular, uh, uh, partial
whatever we are calculating here.
So, and we'll do it for all the parameter we can
also, because we have to change.
So, uh, this left side, whatever you have, this is the new,
new, new pa, new weight, you can say that.
And this right side VK value is the old weight.
So from the old, how much I, I I'm subtracting, okay?
So it may be slightly change
because this value is what we are expecting is, uh, this,
uh, slight change that is what, uh, the slope, what
what I'm expecting is should be, uh,
very less then only I can observe, okay?
How much, how much change which is happening here in this,
uh, at the output layer in the next iteration, right?
So this is the update tool.
So there are two step process which we are going to follow.
First step is to calculate this part, elevator tips
and second step update these parameters
with this update rule.
Now, the question comes here, can we compute
partial derivative of loss with respect to vk
or with respect to WIJ or with respect to bk?
Okay? Can we compute it?
And if at all we compute it, how,
how can we compute it, right?
So that is what we have to see now, okay?
And that's where, uh, your, uh, concentration is required.
So first of all, uh, you may not be able to calculate these,
uh, these, uh, derivative,
partial derivative directly, okay?
Why? Because loss you have calculated at output layer,
and loss was always with win.
Why and why? Cap, okay?
Loss was always between these two pyramid, why
and why cap loss was not between say that, uh, uh,
loss has, uh, not between W one one, okay?
And the output, what you're supposed to get, okay? Mm-hmm.
Loss was not between V one
and whatever output you're supposed to get, loss was
between whatever prediction you are getting
and whatever, uh, ground truth you have.
So we have to start from this, uh, uh,
final output itself,
and we have to see that how, how we can use, uh,
this partial derivative, uh,
and we can, we can still change the,
these, these parameters.
That is what we have to see next. Okay?
So first of all, see this is,
this is the flow which we are going to follow, okay?
So what I want to say is my loss
depends on the prediction, isn't it?
You can see here loss function was y minus y hat, okay?
The actual minus prediction,
and obviously we have used here the square,
so it is Y minus y hat square.
So this is why actual loss.
So my laws depend on Y hat fine.
And if you see that, the Y hat here depends on these five
values, okay?
These five pyramid, these five
values, what are these values?
So you see this, this y hat here in this network,
it is connected with B three.
It is connected with V one, it is connected with V, uh,
V one, V two, and this V one is coming from H one and H two.
So this output neuron where you are getting the yha
is actually depending on these five, so
what will be the yha say that yhat will be 10
or yhat will be 20.
It depends on all these five parameters, okay?
What is B three? What is H one? What is S two?
What is V one and what is V two? Okay?
If any of these parameter will change, y hat will change.
That means that Y hat depends on all these five,
and that is what is represented here.
That my loss depends on, uh, this prediction yha,
but YHA depends on V one, V two, H one, S two,
and B three, right?
Makes sense, I guess, right?
And if you see that, I will now focus
all the parameters which are between this hidden layer
and output layer, and I'll try to update that and to update.
First I will par, I'll do the partial derivative applause
with respect to these three parameter, okay?
That is the first thing what we, so from the network,
if you see that, uh, this YY hat equation,
it depends on V one, H one, V two, H two, and P three.
That is what is shown in this particular figure.
The same equation is now represented in this figure
for the better understanding, okay?
And this red line, what you're seeing, red arrow,
these arrow, these are the arrows which we are going
to first work on, and then we'll go on H one S two,
and then we'll change W one W parameters
and B one B two s, we, we'll go one level back, okay?
So that's the first thing. So let us see that one.
So now the point is, uh, first of all, uh, so
what I said, my loss depends on Y hat, okay?
So if you see the loss equation, it is Y minus yha square.
So partial derivative of loss with respect to yhat.
Now, this is the only direct access we have
for the loss, isn't it?
Because loss is directly depending on yhat,
so I can calculate this one.
So partial derivative of loss with respect to yha will come
as, so it's, it's just like access square, right?
So it'll be two in two y height minus Y, okay?
And this, we are going to use it for further when we will,
uh, uh, expand our partial derivative part.
So now see that this part is done loss to yhat.
We have already traveled.
Now, the point is, uh, from yhat depends on V one,
V two, and B three, okay?
So I'm talking about this layer right now.
I'm not talking about the, uh, first layer, okay?
So I will talk about it later.
So first I will see that how
to calculate the partial derivative of laws with respect
to V one and how to calculate the partial derivative laws
with respect to B2C.
There is no direct access, okay?
So loss is not directly depending on V two loss directly
depends on why, but why depends on V one, V two, okay?
So what I will do is I will, uh,
look at this particular equation.
Y hat is equal two,
y hat is equal two V one H one V two S two plus B three.
So what I'll do is I'll calculate partial derivative of loss
with respect to, uh, uh, this one y hat,
and then I'll calculate partial derivative of, uh,
y hat here with respect to say V one
or with respect to V two or with respect to B three.
Why? Because V one, V two
and B three, these are the parameters which is available
in this particular equation.
V one, H one, V two, S two, B, V three, and three.
So this part we can always calculate, right?
This one, partial derivative of yha with respect to V one,
what will be that H one, isn't it?
That will that, because all these will be the constant
and hence it will be zero.
And here you have, you are only led with the H one.
So partial derivative of yhat with respect to
V one will be S one, and that is what is written here.
And similarly, partial derivative of y hat with respect
to S two will be V two, sorry, uh, of V two with respect
to, uh, V two.
Uh, actually it should be V two. Okay?
This, this, uh, I, I'll change that one
before uploading this.
Uh, so this should be V two, so it'll be H two, right?
And that is what is written here.
And similarly, partial derivative of yhat with respect
to B three will be one, okay?
Because these two component will be zero zero
because this constant, uh, when we are with respect
to B three, we are doing then this part,
this component will be constant.
So zero, this will be zero left with only B three.
So partial dis a partial derivative of yha with respect
to B three will be one.
So now how we are going,
so we are calculating this equation, partial derivative
of loss with respect to V one, when we have to calculate,
so actually we are going doing the chain rule, right?
So partial derivative of loss with respect to yhat,
because that is the only direct text we have,
but partial derivative y hatt with respect to V one,
we can originate because this, this arrow you can follow,
okay, from loss to YHY hatt to V one, this we can go,
this is the channel which we have to follow,
and that is what we have calculated.
And hence we have got, this is Azure derivative,
and we are going to utilize this derivative later
to update our V one and V two update part.
I'll show you later. And similarly, for V two, this is,
this is what is the partial derivative only changes.
In here we have H one.
Here we have H two, and with V three,
we have here one first part is same,
because in the first part we have partial derivative clause
with respect to yhat, which is common for all the three.
Okay? So hopefully this much is clear.
Is there any query in this particular slide so far?
You can ask me,
yes, sir.
Yeah, please. What is the query?
A any, any query you have or it, it's fine.
Yeah, sir, it is fine, sir. Yeah. Okay.
Now we are going to extend the same logic, okay?
Uh, this, this, uh, this tag, uh,
I'll show you diagrammatic representation,
but how to go one level down.
So we are still, we are right now between output layer
and hidden layer, and these are the three parameters,
which we are trying to find the partial derivative, okay?
With respect, uh, with respect to these three parameters.
But now we'll go one level down.
So now you see this, this layer is done. Okay?
Now we need to find, we are at H one,
and then I'll show you for H two.
Okay? So now we are at H one,
because if you see here, uh, this y was depending on V one,
V two, and then why, why, sorry,
Y hat was depending on V one, V two,
and it was also depending on H one, S two, V three, first,
we have solved for these three.
Now we'll proceed for H one and H two. Okay?
So now H one S two, if you, if you can see here,
H one S two is the output which you're getting from the
hidden layer neurons, okay?
It is not the parameters, it is an output,
like yhat is an output from the output neuron.
H one S two is also an output from the hidden layer neurons.
Okay? So, uh, we are not going to update
the H one S two when we are doing the back propagation,
but we are updating V one, V two B three
because these were the parameters.
Okay? So now let us see that what we are going to do.
So at the H one. At the H one. So we have to see that. Okay?
Uh, this H one is now connected with what?
H one is connected with X one, which is IQ X two,
which is CZPA and B one, which is one.
Okay? This is how, these are the three
parameters which are connected.
Now with the H one is the same case.
What we have seen for yhat, we are V one,
V two, and B three are connected.
Similar, DH one is now connected with W one one,
W one two, and B one.
These are the three parameters,
which is connected with the H one.
So like for, uh, uh, when we were here at the output layer,
we calculated the gradient of loss with respect
to V one, V two, and B three with a chain rule.
Similarly, when we are here,
we'll calculate the partial derivative applause with respect
to W one one, W one, two, and B one.
Okay? Uh, uh, at, at, when we are at H one,
similarly, we'll repeat for H two.
I'll show you how to, so first of all, look,
look at these two, these two equation.
So what is happening here at H one?
First of all, you are doing this one,
W one one gets multiplied with X one, W one,
two gets multiplied with X two,
and B one gets multiplied with one.
And hence, you get one value here, which is
represented here, Z one
and this Z one, you are passing through activation function.
Here we are using radio activation function,
getting the H one.
So this is how you are getting the H one value, okay?
The output from the hidden layer, the H one value, okay?
Now, now we need to change the parameter,
W one one, W one, two, B one.
So if at all, we want to change the parameter, W one,
how can we, uh, how can we, uh, see for changing W one, one,
W one two, B one.
You first have to come to that one,
and to come to the ZED one, you've, you have to come
to this of Zed one.
And then, uh, two, and that is what is the H one, right?
So we'll take this path again, I want
to show the path in which we are going to follow,
and hence we'll change W one one, W one, two, and P one.
Okay? So L was,
the loss was depending on Yhat, right?
And YHA was depending on these five parameters,
we have already calculated the gradient for these three,
V one, V two, and V three.
That is already, we have stored, we'll do the update
for V one, V two, V three, late.
Now we are going little back.
Now H one and H two is also left.
So when we start seeing H one, so H one is not a parameter,
so it was an output which we're getting from Z one.
So relu of Z one was the, was giving my, the H one, right?
And Z one was depending on further, further,
it was depending on these five values, W one one, W one two,
X one, X two, B one.
Same thing. Right in place of why if I,
you will remove this one.
You can treat it as this is a neuron,
and this, depending on these five parameters, same thing.
So now, but the point is how to write the chain rule, okay?
Because my loss is not directly depending on W one
one, W one two or B one.
These are parameters which we have to partially, uh, we,
we have to change, but my loss is not directly depending.
So what we'll do, we'll follow this, this path.
The red, the red arrow, you have to follow,
we'll calculate the partial derivative of laws with respect
to yhat, then partial derivative of yhat with respect
to H one, then partial derivative of H one with respect
to Z one, then partial derivative of Z one with respect
to W one two.
That's all. This is what we are going to follow.
So this is very clear how you are going
to write this equation, and this equation
will make sense for you, right?
That why, how it has come, right?
So same thing I've written here, partial derivative of loss
with respect to W one, two is equal two loss with respect
to y hat, y hat is depending on H one, okay?
H one is depending on Z one
and Z one is depending on W one too.
That's all. Now, this part we already have calculated
because it was two into Y hat minus Y one, H one.
We have also calculated when with respect to H one,
we were calculating the output was V one.
Now part cell derivative of H one with respect to Z one.
That is what we need to calculate.
So this is what this, this blue part, you have to see H one
with respect to Z one.
So it, it is the par, it is the activation function part.
It's partial derivative. That is what you have
to calculate, okay?
So, uh, partial derivative of, uh, Z one is, uh,
one, okay?
So if I, I'll just, I'll just show you Relu, uh, derivative,
find real derivative.
How does it look like so
that you will understand this, uh, see this.
So actually the relu function is this fine.
So for negative value, it gives the zero value.
And for positive, it gives this,
this red line, what you're seeing.
If, uh, the positive value is one
or portfolio one positive value
is two, or output will be two.
So that way positive value itself is the output for relu.
But when you calculate the derivative of this relu, it is
one for all the positive, zero for all the negative.
And it is, again, there is a problem here,
which we'll see later on how people have solved.
If the output is zero, the derivative, uh,
you can't differentiate it, right?
Because here it is, but, uh, at least in this network,
we are not in that situation.
So I have used the, so there are many solutions for
that which people have used in terms of say, leaky relu
or many other forms of relu, which we'll talk later.
Okay? But here I wanted to show, this is how the derivative
of the relu looks like.
For all the positive value, the derivative is one
for the all, the negative value derivative will be zero.
Okay? Now, come back here. Okay, so sir,
One, uh, sorry to interrupt one question because
otherwise you'll go too far.
It'll be difficult for me to follow.
Alright, so the last one, uh, like the derivative of Z one,
uh, depending upon W one, two have put it.
Why only one to why not one, one as well?
No, that is also there, but in the next slide,
Okay? Okay, yeah, fine
then. Okay. Yeah.
The one by one, I'm, I'm showing you, so, yeah, sure.
Okay. Yeah, that's fine. Thank you.
Yes, yes. Actually, this,
this first slide is for one, one only.
Here, you see this red line? Actually, I missed that.
So this is one, one.
Next slide is for one, two, and next slide is for B one,
because these are the parameters we have.
Okay? So yeah, so this is for one, one, uh, yeah.
So what will happen?
So what will calculate partial derivative of, uh, uh,
we have already come from here, partial derivative of clause
with respect to Y hat, partial derivative of yha
with respect to H one, H one, with respect to zed one
and the zed one with respect to W one one.
And this is the same. You can see that this
chain rule is written and this is what we have to solve.
If we want to calculate this, uh, uh, partial change
of L with respect to W.
So what will be the change in loss if I slightly, uh,
if there will be a slight change in W one.
Okay, so that if at all you want
to calculate this whole chain rule you have to solve,
and we have all the, all these values.
So first value, we have second value, we have, so relu, uh,
partial derivative of this relu will be,
if Z one is positive, you will have one in place of this.
If this value is negative,
you'll have zero in place of this.
If it is zero, the whole term will be zero.
Whole derivative is going to be zero, okay?
If it is one, then this value will be one that's all.
And partial derivative of this part.
You see, the last one, Z one with respect to W one,
one will be X one, because this term
and this term will be zero zero.
They're all constant for W one one with respect
to W one one, when you are solving
and only X one is left with, so X one will come here,
and this, these all values we have will substitute,
we'll get this value, partially loss with respect to W one.
I'll repeat it for W.
One, two only changes the last one, first three,
partial of same.
Now with respect to W, one, two will do,
and hence here we have X two.
That's all, that's everything is same.
And similarly, the only change with respect
to B one is here we have B one, and this value will B one,
because B one with respect to B one will give you one.
And these two terms are constant anyway, so
it'll not into play.
So yes, now you have all the parameters,
which you are supposed to update their gradients.
Now, you know, so you know B one, V two, B three, W one,
W one, two, and uh, B one, okay?
Yeah, H one. Now, uh, so no, uh,
three more parameters are there.
Sorry. With respect to H one, we have done all these things.
Similarly, you have to do for the S two also,
because the Y is also depending on S two,
for H one, you have solved.
For S two, also, you need to solve.
So next you will see for the S two, for the H two, okay,
this is the H two with the S two, W2 one, W2 are connected.
V two is also connected. Okay?
And S two with the connection of V two is leading us to the
final, uh, output Y yhat and loss is depending on this yhat.
So this is the path we are going to follow.
Loss will depend on yhat, YHA will depend on H two.
H two will depend on the Z two, which is re
of whatever value you are getting fine.
And then Z two will depend on W2 one, W2 two and B two.
And that same thing you can see
now in this particular picture.
Okay? Same thing. First level, these are the parameter,
but now we are only concentrating on S two.
So you have to follow only this red arrow. Okay?
So S two depends on Z two
and Z two is depending on all these parameter,
five parameters one by one will solve for W2 and W2 two,
and B two X one, X two is an input.
So you don't have to solve for the X one, X two
because this is just an input, it's not a parameter.
So you, you are not supposed to update those.
Alright, so now, uh, same, same equation.
So here you see partial derivative of loss with respect
to Y hat, y hat with respect to S two.
Okay? Here, Y hat with respect to S two
and S two with respect to Z two here,
S two is depending on s uh, Z two.
So this, this equation and Z two is depending
on double one, okay?
It's very simple. I think now you, you're able to follow
that how we are writing the chain tool, fine
and all, all these derivative, derivative is not very, uh,
difficult, but only thing is writing the chain tool is
little bit, uh, people get, uh, uh, um, confused sometimes
how to go back and how to write, okay, where,
and all it is depending or not.
So if you will draw this kind of structure, right?
So you'll not get confused,
then finding the derivative is very easy, right?
It's not difficult because this derivative we already have,
uh, second derivative we already have,
because at this layer we have found all the derivative.
When it comes to Z two, it's a relu.
So if Z, uh, oh, here again, uh, this, this would be Z two.
Okay, I'll change this one again, this will be Z two.
So if Z two is positive, the value will be one here.
That's all. So it's a, uh, you can see dash, right?
So it represents the, it is a partial derivative
with respect to this particular function.
Okay? And finally, with respect to Z two, it'll be X two.
It's not X one. Okay?
I'll change this because I was doing this copy paste.
So everything has comes, I'll change. So I'll update this.
So yeah, then finally you will, uh, okay, sorry,
first time we are doing with respect to X one itself.
So this is X one. Next time it is X two, it is correct.
And third time it'll be one because it is B two. Okay?
So now you have all the, uh, partial derivative,
which we are supposed to calculate in order to, uh, uh, uh,
update all these parameters.
Parameters are V one, V two, B three,
and then parameters are W one, one, W one 12, B one,
and here W2 one, W2 two and B two.
All these other parameters.
And for every parameter we have calculated this,
this partial debit.
Okay? And now I am, uh, again taking you, uh, just, just
to recap that, what we have done so far, so that, uh,
then I'll show you how to update these parameters.
So we started with this, uh, what we did,
we have taken first row from our dataset, X one, X two,
and y biases value were 1, 1, 1, set weights.
What initialized randomly with these for our pass.
First we got Z one here,
and then we pass it through the relu.
We got H one. You can see Z one was 6.6.
H one was also 6.6 because positive value.
So the output will be that value itself.
And what will be the partial derivative of this,
this function, relu of Z one one, because it is positive.
So derivative of this Z one will be one, okay?
That we are going to use in the back propagation.
Similarly, Z two S two we got here,
and then y hat, then we calculated the loss,
which was coming, which were, which was coming as 54.17.
Now. Now, what we have to do is once we have got all these,
uh, derivative, uh, uh, uh,
uh, you, uh, sorry, uh, here, now what we are, uh,
all these equations we got, right?
So you see that all these equations we have first got it.
Now we need just need to substitute these value for every,
uh, whether it's the partial derivative of laws
with W one two, then this is the equation we have got,
we have to substitute all the value
and find, okay, what is the,
what is this partial derivative is
coming for all the parameter.
That is what I'm doing now, okay, here.
So for partial derivative loss with respect to V one,
this was the equation which we al already,
we have already solved, and it was coming as two and two.
Why hat minus y, this partial derivative loss with respect
to y hat is two and two y hat minus y.
And if you will solve this one, it'll come at 14.72.
It'll substitute what is Y hat, what is y multiply by two.
It is, it'll come at 14.72,
which I'm writing here as one value.
We have already, okay,
because as one S two also we have got that is 6.6.
I have shown you in the, I guess previous slide here,
H one is 6.6 as two was 1.8.
That is what I'm substituting.
So this particular, uh,
partial derivative is coming at 97.152.
Similarly for V two, and I'll substitute, I'll get 26.496,
and for B three, I'll get 14.72.
I have all these equations ready,
so I cannot simply substitute the value and get there.
What is the partial derivative, which is coming in?
I'll repeat it, I'll repeat it for, uh, the previous layer
where I was finding partial derivative of loss
with respect to W one one.
And this was the equation. If you can recall,
this was the chain rule.
When we solved this chain rule, this was the equation.
We got two and two y hat minus Y into V one.
From this we got relu dash jed one, and here we have X one.
Okay? And if you'll substitute all these values,
you'll get 1 4, 1 3 0.12.
Similarly, for partial delivery blocks, with respect
to one two, you will get 1 41 0.312.
Okay? Here we have it. So it is 1, 1 4, 1 3.
Here we are just eight. So 1, 4, 1 0.31, two. It is good.
Similarly, if you substitute all these,
all these value, all these value, right?
You'll get 14.832.
And now I I, I also did for the other three parameter,
W2 one, W2, two P and P two.
Okay? So all these gradient we calculated,
and these are the, uh,
the values which we are getting from that.
Now, the only part which is left is updating,
updating these parameters.
So left side, what you see, all the gradients value,
these many gradients we have calculated.
And now what we'll do is we'll use this update rule theta
as we call to theta minus partial derivative,
or partial, uh, sorry, theta minus uh,
learning rate into partial derivative of loss with respect
to theta.
And theta will be first time V one.
Then it'll be V two, then it'll be B three.
Then it'll be W one one, W one two, W2, one W2 two B one
and B two one by one, I mean,
although it'll happen in parallel.
So, but we have to substitute for each parameter.
We have to solve this equation for each of these parameters.
What we want to update,
and that is what I'm showing you here.
Only thing is this learning rate I have taken
as one in two 10 to the power minus four, okay?
Minus four. I will give you the reason for that.
But then I have substituted the learning rate here, 10
to the power minus four theta value,
which is the initial value of the V one here, which was,
you can see here, V one initial value was 1.2.
You see this same value have updated.
Now, what is the new value? V one, we are getting 1.19.
So from 1.2, it is changing as 1.19
V two from 0.8, it's changing as 0.79
from V three from one,
because initially all the biases value we have taken as one.
So then it is changing as the weight for the bias,
it's changing as 0.99 W one one from 0.02,
it's changing at minus 0.12 W 12.5.
It is changing 2.48 B one from one changing to 0.99
W2, 1.0 0.04
to minus 0.05 minus 0.3
to minus 0.30 and 1 2, 0 point.
So these are the change.
One thing, what you should observe is there is only slight
change, which, which we are trying to do.
We are not trying to do a big change, okay?
Because we want to, if you, uh, going further, uh,
although we have talked that in the linear regression,
that okay, how this loss function
and, uh, what is the role of the convex, uh, curve, uh, so
that we will be knowing that whether we are going to our,
uh, global mini GLI minimum
or not, we want
to do a slight change in all these parameters
and run the feed forward network again
and calculate the loss again.
And that is what I'm going to do next.
So with this updated parameters, V one, V two, V three,
and all these nine parameters, what I'm going
to do is I'm again going to run the,
run the forward propagation.
So these are all the old parameters.
And when we last time, uh,
run this feed word feedforward network, I end up
with this material 54.1696.
Now, what I'm doing is I am,
I have updated all these parameters, nine parameters, right?
All these parameters, and then,
then I'm again doing the forward propagation, right?
And then it is coming, uh, the,
then I'm calculating the yha,
and then I'm calculating the loss at the last,
which is coming as 4.0 0 5 8 9 0.
Now see what, what has happened?
First time when we randomly initialize the weights, okay?
The, uh, uh, loss for the,
the output which came was 10.36,
and for that loss came was 54.1696.
Second time, when we have adjusted the weight,
the output came as 0.99 and loss came as 4.00.
There is a huge change in the loss from 54 to four
by adjusting the weed just for one para, one, one iteration,
and only for first row.
I have not even used the second row of my, of my data
and third row of my data, okay?
That is one thing you have to observe is yes.
So what you can say that your back preparation is
working, uh, right?
Then it is able to go towards the global minimum
where the loss value, which is zero, that is
what we have to achieve, right?
So it is going towards it.
If you run it for say, that few more number
of hydration, it may achieve that also.
Secondly, I want you to focus on this, this comment, uh,
uh, here, these two point, see, I have taken this, uh,
partial, uh, sorry, learning rate as one into
10, to the power minus.
So 10 to the power minus four, which is nothing of 0.0004.
Now, that is the learning rate value, what I have taken.
So the question is why I have taken that much, why,
why I have taken that learning rate, uh,
and how do I know that that learning rate I have to take?
So first thing is you have to, uh, remember one thing that
I, the intention is
to slightly change all these parameters value
to not change it drastically, okay?
That we either negative side or positive side.
I don't want to change, say that initial value
for the W 1, 1, 0 0 2, I don't want to make it directly 20
in the next titration.
I want to do slight change, okay?
And with that slide chain, I want to see that, okay,
how much, uh, my, my error is improving
or not, which I will continue.
So that is first thing.
Now, what has happened is my, uh, X two, uh,
my X two, if you see here, uh, sorry, X one, it was 80
and X two is eight.
Or I guess, uh, just opposite, I don't know.
So one is going in the scale of tens,
and uh, one is going just like between one to, uh,
because CZP, right?
It is always between one to 10 maybe,
but the, this IQ value will be, uh, like it is 19
and a hundred and so on.
So the, is the scale, scale, scale
of these two features were not proper.
It was not in the same range.
Now, see that that was the reason, okay?
That was the reason. What I did.
I may, I, I chosen my, uh, uh, uh, this learning rate,
uh, very small.
If I have not, I would've not chosen this learning rate very
small, like 10 to the power minus four.
What, what would've happened? Look at here, this one.
So this value, if it is not very small,
this value the gradient value, you see, it is so, so big.
These all gradients value are too big.
So if you have old value minus 1.2, minus 97.3,
the corresponding V one, what you will get will be too high,
and there will be huge change in this.
All of these parameters, right?
And this, this is happening just
because my both, the scale
of both the features are not seen,
and hence in the machine learning, deep learning,
at least in the neural network is suggested that
before going for the fallback propagation,
you do the scaling and you try to, uh, uh, uh, uh, do the,
uh, all the parameters,
all the features should be in the same range.
And, uh, then, then, uh, the,
the algorithm will learn faster.
Like it is happening in this case from 54,
it has come to four.
Although the trick here, what I have played here,
I have taken this learning rate very small,
but usually you don't know what will be the, uh,
what will be your, uh, internal gradients
and all, so you can't be seeing every time
and adjusting this learning rate, right?
So what you do, you work with the features itself,
you make it in the same range, okay?
And then apply some learning rate, which is 0.1, uh,
0.01.
These are the small values, right?
For the learning rate, and that we apply
and we get this change in the parameter,
and then we see that, okay, how much weight is improving?
So large raw feature magnitude produce very large gradients
for corresponding weights.
So consider feature scaling or gradient clipping
or a smaller end or a smaller initialization.
So if that is the case where the features are not in a
similar range, these are all some of the, some
of the solutions for that.
That is what I have updated in this case.
One step improvement in loss does not always mean
better generalization.
It happened here by effectively collapse, uh, uh, uh,
collab collapsing, hidden activation.
So here, what has happened, one more thing, I want
to take you Zed one and zed two, once it came.
So I passed the JED one through the activation function
and partial derivative of Zed one, which is here,
negative has come as zero.
So what has happened, essentially in this case
that I'll go back output,
which is coming at H one, H one becomes zero.
So there is nothing which is going here, right?
And why is predicting the value, which is very small,
zero point, I think nine nine I guess, right?
So in this case, it has worked like this, right?
I I, I was just showing you the, uh, flow, the numbers
and all are not important, right?
But then this is how the back propagation works,
and that is what the intention to show.
Now, I'll stop first to take you some questions, right?
Yeah. And then, um, what I'll do is I'll not go ahead
with the demo today because it's already nine 11.
I'll take the questions rather,
and in the next class when you'll start, we'll start
with this demo, but this demo will be available
with you prior, maybe after this class itself.
You can do the practice and then come
and you can come with the more questions so that we can
start with those in the next class.
Yeah. Now I'm open for the questions. Sir.
Sir, I have one question on this, uh,
back provocation, sir.
As said, where we are computing this back provocation,
we are taking this derivative
of the activation function of the hidden layers.
So, but we can also consider the activation function
of the final output layer.
Yeah, yeah. We have, so that we
are not using the derivative.
Uh, we, we have to, but as I said,
for this particular network, I use reactivation function at
the hidden and layer as linear.
So, uh, yes. So that's why. So that's
Why it, Okay, uh, that's why it is, uh,
I have not shown here,
but actually you have to consider
that also when you will use the sig there,
you have to show that also.
Yeah, but I have not shown that.
Yeah, but actually it's happening.
Yeah, it's a good catch.
So what is, uh, gradient clipping,
Uh, uh, gradient clipping?
I'll explain that. It's, it's, some of these are all, some
of the, you can say that, uh, uh, you can say that, uh, uh,
improvements, uh,
or we say that regularization techniques, okay?
Where the gradients are very high
or like, you can see that right here, it,
it was coming in 97, which is very high, right?
So you can clip, you can actually define that if my range
for the gradient will go more than two, more than five,
you can actually put that threshold, you can clip that.
If it is going more than that,
I will bring back to that value itself.
So that's, so it's already scaling?
Yeah, it is a descaling, yeah. Okay.
Got it, sir. Thank you. Sorry, in the same line,
I wanted to ask, what is small initialization,
which is mentioned in that slide,
Last slide, Yes.
The, there a small initialization.
Uh, so, uh, I think I said a smaller
n uh, what is, sorry, it a or the smaller initialization.
Initialization usually happen
with respect to the parameters.
Okay? So the parameters are also sometimes if you take here,
although I've taken care of that part
where I've taken all these parameters
value very small, right?
0.02, 0.4, 0.5,
but sometimes suppose you, you never know,
like it is 1.2, okay?
Which is, which is comparatively high as compared to 0.02.
So what I say, all these initialization of the parameter,
we usually do very small, okay?
Don't keep high. If you'll keep this part high, then
what will happen, you will end up
with the numbers like that.
Um, but the gradient value, which is very high,
and that will create the other problems.
So it's not always the, uh, input features,
which has to be in a proper range.
It also the parameters, which should be in a smaller range,
like zero to one or minus one,
two plus one or something like that.
So that, so that small initialization is, uh,
pointing towards the parameters
that your parameters value also should be very,
it should be small, yeah. To start with.
Yeah, sure, sir. Thank you. Uh, sir.
Using this back provocation methodology, sir, uh, like
during the process, uh,
so the network learns which are the most impact neurons
whose weights are getting changed
accordingly, we are able to have a better, uh, output.
So that also we can able to infer, uh, like we have a, uh,
here we have only two hidden layers.
Uh, 1, 1 1 hidden layer.
If you have two hidden layers, also this, uh,
error will propagate from output layer back
to the input weights.
So to during the process back provocation.
We can also infer that the,
that which is the neurons which have the most impact based
on which the weight changes accordingly, the output, uh,
has a reduced, uh, error, maybe better loss function.
Maybe, uh, maybe you can track that. Okay.
You can track that, right? Yes.
For example, here, what we have understood at
after first iteration, H one s two value is coming
as zero, right?
So the impact, if you will see impact, if you can,
you can say that that, uh, the para,
the weights in this layer may not have that much impact
by changing the weights in this layer itself,
we have achieved a better value as compared
to the previous one, although it is not a
good example, right?
And it is not a general example,
but yes, you can infer that like that, okay?
And if you can track that one, uh, by, uh,
after every iteration, actually you can print these waves
for, for, for every neuron,
for every layer, and you can see that.
But going forward, it is a small network.
It is still understandable going forward.
When it is, it becomes very deep.
It is very difficult to comprehend any of these things.
Yes, yes, Correct?
Yes. Can,
can you go back few slides, sir?
Uh, I think back. Back, yeah. Yeah.
So I mean, before you started the last slide, right?
I joined a bit late. Probably lost some context for that.
The last slide of prisoner sales.
Okay. Okay, last slide.
So, so here I started
with this feed forward when I explained
Yeah, before that, yeah.
Yes, before that, okay. Yeah. Before, before this.
Oh, before this, uh, this one?
Yeah. One more. One more, one more. Okay. This one?
Yeah. Yeah. This one I didn't,
I didn't get this delta weight formula
we are showing up here, right?
Uhhuh, this is what I was asking.
What is this function here?
Is it the last function or it's, uh, no,
No, I told that time also.
Okay. And then activation function.
Okay? This f Is an activation function,
and this F dash is the
Ative of activation function.
Yes. Yes. Okay. Yeah.
It is red this slide,
But when you are showing the, the weight delta
of the weights are calculated based on loss function, right?
Uh, I was just trying to correlate
Actually, when you will calculate this partial derivative,
you will calculate this partial derivative with respect
to loss, with means partial derivative of loss with respect
to some parameter, okay?
Right? So that is not shown, uh, uh, uh, shown here,
but actually it is happening.
The same thing here. It is not shown
with respect to the loss.
I mean, sorry, uh, for loss with respect to some parameter,
but this is the same thing is derivative with respect to X.
So derivative of what?
Derivative of loss
and, uh, yeah, the same thing, which I have told there.
Okay? Okay, sir. Good, thanks.
Yeah. Any other query from anyone?
So hopefully I,
although, uh, uh, uh, this PAC propagation, uh, it, it is,
is complex, I understand.
And, uh, we will not be able
to show this back propagation when we'll go actually to the,
uh, even deeper architecture further for CNN,
uh, like in this way.
But this is what is the principle of the back propagation,
which you have to now visualize every time when we say back
propagation and the chain rule, this is what is happening.
So now it may give you some, some more sense that, okay,
what is happening and how these weights are updated,
what is this partial derivative
and how this, what is the chain rule, okay?
And how the weights at the input layer being mapped
to the loss, which is coming at the output layer.
All those things I get, you must have got some clarity
and you'll get more clarity once you will do this hands-on.
And those, uh, collab notebook is attached with this,
and we'll share that up to this class.
Yeah.
Ruby is available. Yes, sir. I'm here.
No, why from your side? Ruby,
Sir, I lost my job today.
Oh my God. Sorry, sorry. Oh,
Uh, so sir, I wanted to reach out to you.
Maybe I'll ask your WhatsApp number from someone Now,
maybe I need a project, uh, from your incubation seller,
something, because now I don't have a No
Problem. Don't
worry. You'll talk tomorrow, huh?
Yes, sir. Thank you. Uh,
I'm time typing my mobile number here.
Yes, sir. Which is, uh, my WhatsApp number.
Yes, sir. I'll take it, sir.
So still in a state of shock, sir.
Uh, don't worry.
So whatever happens, it's for good thing only,
Hopefully Sir
Uhhuh, I, I,
is the layoff happening? Uh,
Sorry.
Yeah, kind of. You know, the company has lost some two,
three key accounts.
So now, I mean, they're panicking
and they're just, uh,
taking some rash decisions, so mm-hmm.
That's okay. So don't worry.
So I think, uh, see,
they're really going in a different direction.
That's what I feel.
The requirements are so acute, but,
Uh, oh, yes, sir.
Totally. Some needs knee jerk reaction they're doing.
Yes. And then higher positions are, I mean,
very vulnerable to all this, right?
Correct. Correct, correct, correct. Yeah.
So that's, uh, and, uh, uh,
this one, um, uh, Sunil, can you, uh,
type my mobile number there?
I'm not able to do it in the mobile here.
Yes, yes. Uh, yes.
That my WhatsApp number 9 9 5 4 0 0 8 1 3 8.
Uh, yes. I'm finding where the chat chat works.
Trans, no. Huh? Yes.
Pardon me, sir. Right.
Uh, I'm, I trying to find, where is the chat? Chat box
That below, below. You'll
see that ribbon, no black ribbon.
Otherwise, sir, you speak it aloud. We are all not
Here. Here? Yes.
Nine, nine, someone, Someone has already reached chat.
Okay? Thank You. Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, we'll talk sometime tomorrow.
Yes, sir. I'll send you a message. Thank you, sir. Thank
You. Thank you all. Thank
you.
Wait, wait, sir, don't, uh, lose the chat
because then we'll don't lose the chat immediately.
We this? Yeah. Now.
Okay. Thank, thank you, sir.
Thank you, Sir. Goodnight.